AND BY THE WAY, SOON TO BE
ARGUMENTS PUBLIC.
LET’S SEE IF WE CAN GET IT DONE.
WE ARE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, WE
ARE THE HOME OF THE BRAVE, LAND
OF THE FREE.
THIS IS IMPORTANT.
HAS WRITTEN, THE BILL IS SCARY.
TOPS $6 TRILLION.
FOUR OF TRILLION DOLLARS IS
MONEY FOR THE QUIDDITY FROM THE
FEDERAL RESERVE, IN OTHER WORDS
LOANS FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT, TO TRULY IN HIS NEW
SPENDING, A LOT OF MONEY, A LOT
OF PEOPLE NEED HELP.
I WILL EXPLAIN IN A SECOND.
THEN INCLUDES DIRECT FUNDING,
FEDERAL PAYOUTS TO AMERICAN
WORKERS.
THEY DESPERATELY NEEDED.
THIS HAS GONE ON TOO LONG.
THEY ARE STRUGGLING THROUGH NO
FAULT OF THEIR OWN.
WORKERS, SMALL BUSINESSES AND
ENTIRE INDUSTRIES NOW NEED OUR
HELP AND NOW HELP HOPEFULLY WILL
BE ON THE WAY WITHOUT THESE
DELAYS.
THIS BILL ALSO PROVIDES MUCH
NEEDED FINANCIAL RELIEF OR A
SMALL BUSINESSES, THE HEART AND
SOUL OF OUR BUSINESS INDUSTRY IN
THE COUNTRY AND EVEN LARGE
INDUSTRIES WHO ARE ON THE BRINK
OF COLLAPSE FROM OTHER
BUSINESSES WIPED OUT TEMPORARILY
AND WITH THAT SAID, LET ME SAY
THIS TO ALL YOU DEMOCRATS AND
REPUBLICANS IN WASHINGTON, I
DON’T TRUST ANYTHING THAT YOU
DO.
ANY FRAUD, ANY ABUSE, ANY
CORRUPTION, AND A GIVEBACK, ANY
SPECIAL BENEFITS FOR CEOs,
STOCK BUYBACKS, WE WILL BE
CALLING ALL OF YOU OUT BY NAME
AND HOLDING ALL OF YOU
ACCOUNTABLE.
WITH THIS CRISIS, EVERY SINGLE
PENNY THAT WE PUT FORWARD NEEDS
TO GO TO THE AMERICAN WORKERS.
THAT ARE IMPACTED.
SMALL BUSINESSES AND THE
BUSINESSES THAT ARE LARGER
IMPACTED BY THE VIRUS.
FOR DAYS, WE HAVE NOW BEEN
WATCHING A ADAM SCHIFF SHOW, AT
THEIR ABSOLUTE WORST.
THIS HAS BEEN REPULSIVE.
THIS IMPORTANT LEGISLATION NOW
HAS BEEN BLOCKED FOR DAYS BY
THESE RADICAL LEFTISTS HURTING
WORKERS AND HURTING BUSINESS,
HURTING PEOPLE THAT NEED HELP.
PELOSI, SCHUMER, AND COMPANY
DECIDED THIS WOULD BE THE
PERFECT TIME TO PLAY DIRTY
POLITICAL GAMES WHERE THEY
WANTED TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF A
DEADLY VIRUS, USE THAT TO PUSH
THE RADICAL SOCIALIST AGENDA
INCLUDING BUCKET LOADS OF
WASTEFUL UNRELATED SPENDING
PROPOSALS.
MANY OF WHICH CAN BE FOUND IN
THE NEW GREEN DEAL INSANITY.
A LOOK AT YOUR SCREEN.
THIS IS NANCY PELOSI.
THIS IS WHAT NANCY PELOSI HAS
BEEN FIGHTING FOR, OR WISH LIST
INCLUDING TAX CREDIT FOR WIND
AND SOLAR POWER, STRICT NEW
REGULATIONS AGAINST THE ALREADY
STRUGGLING AIRLINE INDUSTRY.
WHY DON’T WE JUST KICK THEM IN
THE TEETH WHILE THEY ARE
STRUGGLING INCLUDING MANDATORY
ADMISSIONS REDUCTIONS FOR THEIR
GREENHOUSE GAS STATISTICS FOR
INDIVIDUAL FLIGHTS, KICK THE
AIRLINE INDUSTRY IN THE TEETH
WHEN THEY ARE DOWN.
IS DESPICABLE WHAT THEY ARE
DOING AND THAT’S NOT ALL.
THE SOCIALIST WISHLIST ALSO
PROPOSES $35 MILLION.
THIS WILL MAKE EVERY AMERICAN
WORKER THAT IS STRUGGLING TO
MAKE THEIR RENT, THEIR MORTGAGE
PAYMENT OR THEIR CAR PAYMENT
WONDERING IF THEY’RE GOING TO BE
ABLE TO SEND THEIR KIDS TO
COLLEGE.
THEY WANT TO PUT THE KENNEDY
PERFORMING ARTS, $35 MILLION FOR
THAT TO FIX THAT UP.
THAT’S WHAT THE DELAY IS ABOUT?
IN A TIME LIKE THIS, PELOSI
REALLY NEEDS HER FAVORITE OPERA
HOUSE SO SHE CAN STAY IN TIP-TOP
EMOTIONAL SHAPE AND THEN THERE
IS MORE.
DEMANDING NEW PROTECTIONS FOR
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
IS THIS THE TIME?
THE AUTOMATIC EXTENSION OF
NONIMMIGRANT VISAS SWEEPING NEW
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING POWERS,
RACIAL DIVERSITY QUOTAS ON THE
BOARDS OF MAJOR COMPANIES.
IN THE ELIMINATION OF STUDENT
DEBT, NEW MANDATE REQUIRING
STATES TO ALLOW SAME-DAY VOTER
REGISTRATION.
HOW ARE WE GOING TO CHECK THAT
OUT?
AND WANTS TO BRING BACK THE
OBAMA PHONE.
THAT’S RIGHT, HER BILL INCLUDES
FEDERAL SUBSIDIES FOR
CELL PHONES.
NOW WHAT DOES ANY OF THIS HAVE
TO DO WITH CORONAVIRUS?
YOU MIGHT ASK THAT QUESTION.
THE ANSWER IS ABSOLUTELY NOTHING
NOTHING.
SUFFERING AMERICANS HAVE BEEN
WAITING THE WHOLE TIME IN THIS
CRISIS AND THIS IS HOW THEY ACT
AND WHAT THEY DO.
EVERY AMERICAN SHOULD BE
DISGUSTED TONIGHT.
THREE LONG YEARS, HATE TRUMP,
AND DO NOTHING ELSE.
NOTHING TO MAKE US MORE SAFE,
SECURE, PROSPEROUS, NOTHING.
DO ANY OF THESE RADICAL
SOCIALIST PROPOSALS, ARE THEY
GOING TO GET PAYCHECKS TO
RESTAURANT WORKERS, SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS AND THOSE
EMPLOYEES OR ANYONE ELSE
SUFFERING?
NOT A THING.
AT A TIME WHEN AMERICANS
ACTUALLY COULD USE THEIR
GOVERNMENTS STEPPING UP TO WORK
FOR AND SERVE WE THE PEOPLE
PPOSED TO BE PUBLIC SERVANTS,
THEY ARE GETTING THE MIDDLE
FINGER FROM WASHINGTON.
A NATIONAL DISGRACE UNFOLDING
TONIGHT.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WE SAW THE SPEAKER OF THE
HOUSE RELEASE AND ENCYCLOPEDIA
OF UNRELATED DEMANDS AS THOUGH
IT WERE A CORONAVIRUS PROPOSAL
SOMEHOW.
>> DEMOCRATS HAVE BEEN DELAYING
A MAJOR RELIEF BILL IN HOPES
THAT THEY CAN INCLUDE A LAUNDRY
LIST OF THEIR PET PROJECTS.
PROJECTS THAT HAVE ABSOLUTELY
NOTHING TO DO WITH PROVIDING
FINANCIAL RELIEF TO AMERICANS.
>> I HONESTLY CANNOT BELIEVE WE
ARE STILL HERE NOT HAVING
ALREADY PASSED LEGISLATION THAT
WOULD MAKE SUCH A BIG
DIFFERENCE.
>> I HAVE NEVER BEEN MORE
DISGUSTED SINCE KAVANAUGH.
>> Sean: LET’S GET THIS
STRAIGHT, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
PAY TO REBUILD EUROPE AFTER
WORLD WAR II.
WE CONTINUE TO SEND A CONSTANT
BILLIONS AND BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
IN INTERNATIONAL AID ALL OVER
THE WORLD.
WE DEFEATED NAZISM, FASCISM,
COMMUNISM AND MORE RECENTLY,
RADICAL ISLAMIC TERRORISM.
WE SAVE THE WORLD AND PAID THE
HIGHEST PRICE FOR EVIL AGAIN AND
AGAIN AND GOTTEN THROUGH A
NUMBER OF OTHER CONFLICTS AND
PANDEMICS AND DEPRESSION BUT NOW
CONGRESS CAN’T GET PAYCHECKS TO
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE IN NEED AT
THIS HOUR BECAUSE NANCY PELOSI
WANTS MORE WINDMILLS AND CARBON
OFFSETS.
JUST LIKE THE LAST THREE YEARS,
WHAT THEY ARE DOING IS HURTING
THE COUNTRY AND THANKFULLY
TONIGHT DESPITE THE ECONOMIC